can we talk about
um your life coming from Ghana to
Britain your Refugee background I wonder
what you think of how refugees are being
treated in Britain today
I'm thinking about Ukraine and the
Rwanda policy this country was built on
refugees people from India you know
people from Africa you know the
Commonwealth sort of embraced all these
countries so I feel like sending people
to real Rwanda is not really the
solution you know I'm a refugee and I
think refugees contribute to the country
so we have to be and you know we have to
have empathy
you know and I think sometimes empathy
it's quite hard for people to
to show I think that's that's the only
way forward when it comes to refugees so
would you like to see a change in that
policy in terms of with your background
and you know there are so many stories
similar to yours actually because
government ministers would you like to
see that policy gone and something more
inclusive more helpful replacing it I
mean I would love to see a more helpful
inclusive policy in place because when
you tell people that they're not needed
when you tell people they're not wanted
that's that's that's a problem in itself
you might be saying no to the next
person the next Doctor Who's going to
discover the next vaccine or the next
pre you know prime minister you could be
turning
incredible people away so we have to be
very careful there is this
um phrase at the moment being woke and
all of a sudden it seems on Trend to be
anti-woke and a lot of that you know the
Prime Minister the new prime minister
has seen as anti-woke
do you think there's space for both in
terms of
you know what does being woke mean to
you and what's the backlash why is there
a backlash to you know speaking about
issues that matter to me the word woke I
don't even know what it means you know
I'm a result of wokeness if you want I'm
you know I was somebody who was welcomed
into the UK you know so for me just a
country that is Unified regardless of
your background will always be a great
thing for me so I don't really take that
word on board
can we talk about Black History Month
talk to me about why that is important
and why you want to devote the magazine
during that month to black history I
mean you know black history is not
ignored quite a lot of the times and I
feel like we have to sort of teach a new
generation not just black people but
people of all colors what black people
have been through what it's taken to get
here and also how to be compassionate
how to sort of work together live
together and create a real Society where
you know everybody really gifts their
best so
Black History Month is really now more
important than ever if you look at the
current government it's one of the most
diverse in history do you think they
should be doing better given the
visibility of different races in
government are they actually walking the
walk
I mean I think we all should do better
anybody with a platform any sort of
famous
person of color should really do better
um for me I can't you know speak for the
politicians but I know that in the
fashion industry
there was a reckon in when George Floyd
was murdered and every day I talk about
employment behind the scenes giving
people from different backgrounds you
know not just internships but also you
know mid-level roles and CEO roles if
that's really what in my industry what
I'm doing
are you disappointed we didn't see
Britain's first prime minister of color
in Rishi sunak
you know I mean it's a different time it
would have been great but you know
this wasn't the time that's all you can
really say
what are the chances of the new prime
minister Liz truss being featured in
Vogue apparently she asked Nicholas
sturgeon the first Minister how to get
in Vogue what does she have to do to get
into the magazine I mean you know we we
feature people who are sort of doing
things at the moment who have something
to do with the psych guys so I'm just
you know we're waiting to see you know
how she progresses and then we'll we'll
have that conversation again
he would be your ultimate cover star
I feel we've touched you know we've had
so many incredible people on the cover
I always wanted the queen for her
services to
you know a duty moving forward I mean I
really love the covers we did in
lockdown which is sort of Judy Dench at
85 and the essential worker so I'd love
to sort of
and here comes the exclusive I'd love to
have sort of more real women on the
cover women who are not necessarily
movie stars or musicians but really
represent the world represent
their worlds that they're in